.
* Sanfter, mystischer Frauengesang *
Island, 22 Uhr:
Ausflugszeit hierzulande.
Letztes Jahr haben wir es nie
geschafft, aber nun freuen wir uns,
diesen Ort
nach Feierabend zu besuchen.
Auswanderer Steff Felix
und seine Frau Isabelle
sind unterwegs zum Outdoor-Wellness.
* Bellen *
Ich sehe ihn schon reinspringen.
* Lachen *
* Erwartungsvolle Trommelklänge *
Das ist ein heisser Wasserfall,
unter dem man baden kann.
Die Mücken sind nicht so cool,
aber wenn es nicht windet,
hat es halt Mücken.
* Erwartungsvolle Trommelklänge,
mystischer Frauengesang *
Etwa 40 °C hat das Wasser.
* Sanfter, mystischer Frauengesang *
Auf Mallorca übernimmt der
erfahrene Gastronom Otmar Gemperli
mit seinem Partner Gabor Balogh
ein Restaurant.
Corinna, die bisherige Besitzerin,
hilft die erste Saison mit.
Die Pflanzen da vorn nehme ich mit.
Ich habe es dreimal gesagt:
Sie kommen auf den Balkon.
Kaputt.
Nach und nach soll sie
das Lokal an Otmar übergeben.
Jetzt ist geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Aber schon kurz nach der Eröffnung
droht der Traum zu platzen.
Wegen gesundheitlicher Probleme
nimmt sich Otmar
eine Auszeit in der Schweiz.
Ein Restaurant in Mallorca ist schon
seit mehr als 20 Jahren mein Traum.
Das kann es jetzt
nicht gewesen sein.
Er lässt sich nicht unterkriegen
und kommt gestärkt mit Gabor
nach Mallorca zurück.
Ich freue mich, wieder hier zu sein.
Wir schaffen das gemeinsam.
Die vier Mädels
kriegen gleich etwas zu essen.
Tisch 8 muss begrüsst werden.
Die Stimmung zwischen Corinna
und den Auswanderern aber
ist zunehmend angespannt.
Möchtet ihr schon etwas trinken?
- Tschau.
Ein Jahr ist es her, dass Familie
Tscharner die Schweiz verlassen hat.
In Florida sollen
die Ferienträume Alltag werden.
Ich kann es noch nicht glauben.
- Jetzt wohnen wir am Meer.
Sie investieren
in mehrere Immobilien.
Das Haus in Alligator Point
bauen sie zu einem Beach House um.
Alles unter Wasser.
* Donnern *
Jetzt müssen wir wohl reingehen.
Auch
mit dem selbst renovierten Wohnwagen
auf ihrem Gelände
wollen sie Geld verdienen.
Die Fahrt mit dem Schulbus
ist das tägliche Highlight
von Tochter Lily Rose.
Schon bald darf auch Schwester
Ruby Sue in den Kindergarten.
Die Nordlichter gehören zum neuen
Leben von Isabelle und Steff Felix.
Ihre Ferienlodge in Island wollen sie
um drei Tiny-Häuser erweitern.
Die Fundamente sind
die erste grosse Herausforderung.
Eine Bautruppe aus der Schweiz
stellt die Häuser auf.
Den Innenausbau stemmen die beiden
über Monate allein.
Er ist schon zufrieden mit mir - es
bleibt ihm ja nichts anderes übrig.
Parallel dazu der Gästebetrieb.
Noch aber fehlt etwas Entscheidendes.
Für unsere drei Apartments
haben wir Wasser,
aber für die drei Tiny-Häuser nicht.
Nach einem arbeitsreichen Winter
erschliessen sie die Quelle.
Ob sie aber genug Wasser bringt,
ist unklar.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist Sommer in Island.
Noch immer ist die Hengifosslodge
am Ufer des Lagarfljót
eine Baustelle.
Der Gästebetrieb
läuft auf Hochtouren.
Für uns ist das super.
Wir freuten uns,
dass Schweizer kommen.
Pausenlos läuft die Waschmaschine.
Die Bett- und Frotteewäsche
wollten sie eigentlich
in eine Reinigung geben.
Doch diese
musste den Betrieb einstellen.
Das Problem ist, dass
die Wäscherei heruntergebrannt ist.
Sie war auch die einzige
hier dieser Gegend, die das anbot.
Der nächste Wäscheservice
ist 1 1/2 Std. von hier entfernt.
Das lohnt sich
für uns einfach nicht.
Immerhin: Während der Schulferien
haben sie Unterstützung.
Laufey, die Tochter einer Nachbarin,
hilft beim Putzen mit.
(Englisch)
Das Reinigen der Apartments
ist zur Hauptsaison
um einiges aufwendiger als gedacht.
Mit drei Wohnungen
hätten wir das
schon allein stemmen können.
Aber wenn noch
drei Häuser hinzukommen ...
... können wir das
allein fast nicht stemmen.
Zwischen Check-out und Check-in
bleiben ihnen nur wenige Stunden.
Als gelernter Steinmetz
ist es Steff gewohnt, anzupacken.
Den kompletten Innenausbau
der Tiny-Häuser
haben die Auswanderer selbst gemacht:
Wände verkleiden,
Fliesen legen, Möbel montieren.
Selbst vor Sanitärarbeiten
schreckt Steff nicht zurück.
Seit einem Jahr sind sie dran -
permanent.
Ich glaube, Isa ist froh,
wenn dieses Projekt, diese
drei Häuser endlich fertig sind.
* Er ächzt. *
So.
Und wären Bau und Gästebetrieb
nicht schon genug,
kam Tausendsassa Steff
noch mit einem weiteren Projekt.
Dann hatte ich noch die Idee,
Bäume anzupflanzen.
Darüber freute sie sich nicht so.
Ich wusste aber auch nicht,
dass diese 4'500 Bäume
in einer Woche im Boden sein müssen.
Ja, die Belastung
ist schon ziemlich gross:
diese Häuser fertigstellen,
drei ausgebuchte Gästewohnungen
und diese Woche
noch 4'500 Bäume pflanzen.
Aber dafür haben wir etwas
für die nächste Generation getan.
Ein Häuschen weiter
ist Isabelle im Endspurt -
in zwei Tagen schon
stehen die ersten Gäste vor der Tür.
Noch aber ist nicht alles fertig.
Heiss, heiss.
- Also, wo hättest du ihn gern?
Ja ...
- Hier? Weiter oben?
So?- Ja, warte,
lass mich kurz überlegen.
Vielleicht noch etwas weiter in die
Mitte. Wenn man die Tür öffnet ...
Drüben bei der Steckdose auch nicht.
Nein, hier müsste es okay sein.
Ein weiteres Mal
ist Teamwork gefragt.
Manchmal ist es schwierig
und manchmal sind wir einer Meinung.
Manchmal sorgt Island dafür, dass
eine Idee nicht realisierbar ist,
weil es das hier nicht gibt.
Das ist tatsächlich
ein Island-Kompromiss.
Im Dorf gibt es ein Baugeschäft
und dort hat es, was es hat.
Ja, ich kann damit leben
und es ist okay.
Ich hoffe, dem Gast gefällt es auch.
Er weiss ja nicht,
dass unsere Idee eigentlich war,
dass der Haken silberfarben ist.
Es erleichtert einem
auch sehr vieles.
* Sie lacht. *
Gut.
Ist es hier schon sauber? Nein.
- Nein.
(Englisch)
Auswanderer Mario Tscharner hat sich
mit Nachbar Snorrii verabredet.
Snorrii soll Mario helfen,
eine Glastüre einzubauen -
in Tscharners
neustem Renovationsobjekt.
Good morning.
Das Haus in Carrabelle
ist die vierte Immobilie,
die Familie Tscharner gekauft hat.
Good morning.
- Gib mir das.- Thank you.
Dieses Haus finde ich
nach wie vor ganz furchtbar.
Wenn ich mich umsehe,
sehe ich in jeder Ecke etwas,
was wir noch renovieren müssen.
Es ist einfach viel Arbeit,
aber bei den meisten Dingen
sehe ich keine Probleme.
Du sagst immer: "Kein Problem."
- No problem, nicht, Snorrii?
No problem.
- Das ist sein Lieblingsspruch.
I hold that.
- Alles kein Problem.
In der Tat: Familie Tscharner
scheint vieles richtig zu machen.
Das Mobile Home in Alligator Point
haben sie inzwischen fertig umgebaut.
Als Wildwest Beach House
vermieten sie es an Touristen.
Auch ihr Apartment am Ufer des
Ochlockonee River ist gut gebucht.
* Rockige Musik *
(Mario)
Mhm.
Ihr braucht mich hier nicht, oder?
- Nein.
Gut, dann gehe ich rüber.
- Ja.
Das Haus in Carrabelle besteht
aus zwei getrennten Wohnungen.
Der Preis für Schweizer Verhältnisse
ein Schnäppchen.
Diese Baustelle habe ich übernommen.
Das ist die kleine Wohnung nebenan.
Zuerst dachten wir darüber nach,
das Ganze zu verbinden.
Das war unsere anfängliche Idee.
Unsere Freunde
waren jedoch der Meinung,
dass es besser ist,
die Wohnungen einzeln zu vermieten.
Dieser Meinung sind wir nun auch.
Ich glaube, das ist besser.
So hat man separate Einheiten.
Man kann sie jedoch
trotzdem an eine Familie vermieten,
da die Tür direkt nebenan ist.
Dieses Zeug ist wie Kaugummi.
So.
Während Mario
die groben Arbeiten erledigt,
kümmert sich Melanie um die Details.
Die gelernte Coiffeuse ist für die
Apartment-Ausstattung verantwortlich.
(Snorrii)
Alte Häuser günstig erwerben,
sie renovieren und vermieten
oder mit Gewinn weiterverkaufen -
das ist das Geschäft der Rheintaler.
* Mario und Snorrii lachen. *
(Mann) Hey, Snorrii.
- Hey.
Für den Einbau
der zentnerschweren Türe
kommt noch
ein weiterer Helfer vorbei.
Durch ihre offene Art haben
Tscharners schnell Freunde gefunden.
Diese Gegend ist bekannt dafür,
dass man einander hilft.
Man muss halt bereit sein,
auch mal anderen zu helfen.
Dann kommen sie wieder.
Okay, you got the door.
Yeah.
In Zukunft will Mario jemanden
einstellen, der ihm beim Bauen hilft.
Doch noch hat er niemanden gefunden.
* Mario schreit auf. *
Ja, ja, ja.
- Huh!
It fits.
Mario!
Ja.
Tschau.- Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, Snorrii, bye, John.
Bye, Melanie.
45 Min. Fahrt sind es
von der Baustelle in Carrabelle
bis zum Kindergarten.
Tochter Ruby Sue
wartet schon auf Melanie.
Die Situation ist für mich
momentan etwas nervig.
Ich bin ständig am Autofahren.
Das ist meistens mein Part.
Daher heisst es auch Mama-Uber.
(Melanie)
Zieh deinen Rucksack
und deine Jacke aus.- Hallo.
Wow, the fire truck.
Ruby Sue geht seit zwei Monaten
in den Kindergarten.
Melanie
fährt nicht direkt nach Hause.
Neuerdings muss sie
einen weiteren Stopp einplanen:
bei der Schule von Lily Rose.
Denn es gab
einen folgenreichen Zwischenfall.
Es gab einen Schulbusunfall.
Jemand stiess seitlich
mit dem Schulbus zusammen.
Ich wusste genau,
dass Lily Rose im Bus war.
Glücklicherweise
hat sich Lily Rose nicht verletzt.
Nur: Seit dem Unfall will sie sich
nicht mehr in den Schulbus setzen.
Für sie war es schlimm,
das Polizei- und Feuerwehraufgebot
mitzuerleben.
Sie wusste nicht, was passiert.
Das war schlimm für sie.
Nun hole ich sie halt ab
und bringe sie hin.
Für Melanie heisst das
fast 3 Std. Autofahren pro Tag.
(Melanie)
Und, wie war's?
- Gut.
Morgens hatten wir einen Test.
Lief es gut?
- Ja.
Super.
33 °C und Sonnenschein auf Mallorca.
Die Touristen geniessen ihre Ferien.
Ganz anders Otmar Gemperli
im Brisas del Mar.
Der Gastronom aus dem Kanton Luzern
steckt mitten in der
arbeitsreichsten Phase der Saison.
Zusammen mit Partner Gabor Balogh
ist er sechs Tage die Woche
im Restaurant.
Die anfängliche Unsicherheit
von Gastroneuling Gabor
ist Routine gewichen.
Die Freiheit gefällt mir sehr.
Aber manchmal
möchte ich nicht bedienen.
Manchmal habe ich
keine Lust auf Menschen
und möchte
nur hinter der Bar stehen.
Otmar! Müssen wir das
jetzt bezahlen?- Ja.
Der Gaslieferant
kommt einmal pro Woche.
Man muss immer eine Gasflasche
auf die Strasse rausstellen.
Dann hält er an und fragt,
wie viele Gasflaschen man braucht.
Die muss man gleich bar bezahlen.
Hast du keine Einer?
- Hinten im Schrank sind welche.
(Englisch)
Seit ein paar Wochen
ist Otmar der alleinige Chef.
Corinna, die das Restaurant
zehn Jahre lang führte,
hat sich vorzeitig zurückgezogen.
Die letzten Verhandlungen
mit Corinna waren extrem.
Wir mussten noch alles klären
und gingen eigentlich
im Streit auseinander.
Dann haben wir uns
aber wieder etwas gefunden.
Ich bin froh, dass das Restaurant
nun zu 100 % mir gehört.
Jetzt ist alles gelöst und erledigt.
Den neuen Pachtvertrag hat Otmar
gleich über fünf Jahre abgeschlossen,
mit Option auf weitere fünf Jahre.
Er glaubt fest
an seine Vision des Brisas.
Ich glaube,
sie hatte Schwierigkeiten damit,
dass wir so viel veränderten.
Das hatte sie nicht erwartet.
Aber ich hätte
so nicht arbeiten können
und es wird noch
viel mehr Veränderungen geben.
Auch die Nebenräume
werden wir rigoros ausmisten.
Veränderung bei der Einrichtung,
Beständigkeit beim Personal.
Gute Mitarbeiter sind rar,
das weiss Otmar genau.
Ihnen trägt er daher besonders Sorge.
Jeden Morgen gibt es
einen Kaffee und etwas Süsses
für die lieben Köche.
Kaffee.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn wir Zeit haben,
setzen wir uns gemeinsam hin.
Zurzeit ist es etwas schwierig.
Dann trinken sie ihn in der Küche.
Der 50-Jährige
ist in seiner neuen Rolle
als Restaurantbesitzer angekommen.
Seine gesundheitlichen Probleme
sind Vergangenheit.
Gesundheitlich fühle ich mich gut.
Etwas mehr Freizeit wäre schön.
Wir freuen uns jeweils auf
den Mittwoch, unseren freien Tag,
an dem wir durchatmen können.
Jetzt würde ich mich auch gern
hinsetzen und einen Kaffee trinken.
Otmars Kaffeepause aber muss warten.
Morgen.
Jetzt kommt schon die erste Gruppe.
Ein weiterer arbeitsreicher Tag
mit vielen Gästen beginnt.
Guten Tag miteinander.
Die Bauarbeiten in der Lodge
stehen für einmal still -
trotz engem Zeitplan.
4'500 Baumsetzlinge warten darauf,
gepflanzt zu werden.
Halt den Finger in eines der Löcher.
Die Bäumchen
bezog Steff vom Forstdienst.
Aufforsten wird in Island gefördert.
Denn nur 2 % der Landesfläche
sind bewaldet.
(Englisch)
(Mann)
Forstberater Borja will sehen,
wie die Schweizer
mit dem Pflanzen vorankommen ...
Hier.
... und ob sie beim Setzen
alles richtig machen.
(Borja)
Mit Birken, Fichten,
Lärchen und Pappeln
möchte Steff ihren bereits
bestehenden Wald vergrössern.
Nur: Die Pflänzchen müssen
innerhalb einer Woche im Boden sein.
So lautet Borjas Vorgabe.
Er fragte, ob wir noch mehr wollen.
Aber das kriege ich
bei Isa nicht durch.
Ich bin schon happy und
absolut dafür, so etwas zu machen,
aber ich finde, zurzeit ist
nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt dafür.
Ich hätte noch 1'000 Ideen.
Es ist eher eine Herausforderung für
Isa. Ihr wird es irgendwann zu viel.
Aber, ja ...
Sie hat Ja gesagt.
Steff ist optimistisch,
dass sie das Pflanzen
rechtzeitig abschliessen können.
Isabelle hingegen
ist sich nicht so sicher.
(Isabelle)
(Borja)
Alright.
- Okay.- Sjáumst.
Sjáumst.
Bye. Nun haben wir noch etwas Luft.
Darüber sind wir froh.
Fertig gepflanzt,
die übrigen Bäumchen können warten.
Schoko-Coulant.
- Wo ist die Schokolade?
Das muss nicht immer so ...
Doch, es muss Schokolade drauf sein.
Für Schokolade
braucht man Schokolade.
Tisch 18.
Bis zu 250 Gerichte und Desserts
serviert die Brisas-Crew Tag für Tag.
Gracias.
- Bitte schön.
Umsatz bringen aber
auch die Getränke.
Ein Kunde hat mallorquinischen
Kräuterlikör bestellt.
Oh, es ist zu wenig?
Einen Moment, bitte.
Otmar!
Er sagt, er bezahle nicht
so viel dafür. Es sei zu wenig.
Das sieht nur so aus,
weil kein Eis drin ist.
Giess einfach mehr rein, bitte.
Es ist genau so,
wie es auf der Karte steht.
Das musst du ihm sagen.
- Das habe ich ihm gesagt.
Wir müssen Geld verdienen.
Bitte schön.
Gabor löst das Problem
auf seine Art -
mit einer Portion Leichtigkeit.
Den kleinen Disput hat auch Otmar
schon bald wieder vergessen.
Eigentlich klappt vieles gut.
Manchmal bräuchte man
einfach drei Hände.
* Entspannte, mediterrane Klänge *
Spareribs?
Mit dem Abendservice beginnt für
Gabor die stressigste Zeit des Tages.
Es ist so viel
und ich muss mich konzentrieren.
Über 10 Std. ist Gabor
schon im Restaurant.
Ich bin so müde.
Extrem.
Mir war schon bewusst,
dass man keinen ruhigen Job hat,
wenn man im Restaurant arbeitet.
Aber ich dachte nicht,
dass es so anstrengend ist.
Otmar hingegen kann
die Müdigkeit besser wegstecken.
Im hinteren Teil des Restaurants
hat er sich ein Büro eingerichtet.
Mitten im Betrieb
ist es ihm am wohlsten.
Und das eigene Geschäft
scheint ihn zu beflügeln.
Verglichen mit dem August
letzten Jahres
machten wir über 15 % mehr Umsatz.
Wir haben sehr gut gearbeitet.
Dafür war der Juni
etwas schwächer als im Vorjahr.
Das kompensiert das Ganze.
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Der Umsatz stimmt.
Der Trend ist gut.
Ich hoffe, es geht so weiter.
(Mann) Es war superlecker.
- Danke schön. Einen schönen Abend.
Alles läuft nach Plan - endlich.
Hallo.
Für zwei Personen?
- (Frau) Ja.- Bitte schön.
7 Uhr in der Früh in Florida.
Eine Familie, die im Wildwest
Beach House übernachtet hat,
checkt bereits aus.
* Rockige Musik *
Ein paar Kilometer weiter
in Sopchoppy
sind Mario und Melanie im Stress.
Klemm mir
nicht wieder die Finger ein.
Sie bereiten ihr Motorboot vor.
Nicht für eine Strandhochzeit,
sondern für den ersten Ausflug
mit zahlenden Gästen.
Stopp! Stopp!
- Du musst ein Handzeichen machen.
Fahr nochmals etwas nach vorn.
Noch ein bisschen. Ja.
Jetzt bist du zu weit vorn.
- Herrgott!
Du bist extrem nervös
und fährst total schnell.
Ja, wir sind zu spät dran.
- Wie immer.
Wenn man das macht,
wenn man gestresst ist ...
... dann ist es nicht so optimal.
Das ist eigentlich
für einen Wohnwagen gedacht.
Ich sage ja:
Du bist der Swiss MacGyver.
Du bist in jeder Hinsicht
der Swiss MacGyver.- Ja.
* Dynamische Rockmusik *
In Alligator Point beginnt Amanda
mit der Reinigung des Hauses.
Personal anstellen
ist eine der Auflagen,
die die Auswanderer für
ihr Investorenvisum erfüllen müssen.
Melanie.
- Was ist?
Kannst du mir helfen?
Bis jetzt musste ich dir nie helfen.
Ich hätte
gar nicht mitkommen müssen, oder?
Ja, aber wenn du schon mal da bist,
kannst du darauf achten,
dass es nicht wegdriftet.
Schau, jetzt kommen sie.
- Welcome.
Very nice to meet you.
- Hi. - Christina.
Die Frauen sind durch Flyer
auf die Bootstour von Tscharners
aufmerksam geworden.
Es geht auf den Wakulla River.
Schade,
dass ich nicht mitkommen kann.
Aber was soll's, so ist es halt.
- Okay.
Tschüss.- Danke für die Hilfe.
- Have fun.
(Melanie)
* Entspannte Rockmusik *
Melanie fährt nach Alligator Point.
Sie möchte dort
im Beach House nachsehen.
Ist wirklich alles bereit
für neue Gäste?
Was hat sie denn hier gemacht?
Hm ...
Hier ist irgendwie alles verschoben.
Gut.
Fast ein Jahr haben Melanie und Mario
an diesem Haus gearbeitet.
Sie haben das Dach erneuert,
die Küche ersetzt,
die Badezimmer modernisiert,
einen Wasserschaden repariert
und neuen Boden verlegt.
Wir benötigten
extrem lange für den Umbau.
Irgendwann
verloren wir den Spass daran.
Dadurch ging es
natürlich nicht schneller.
Als wir bereit
für die Sommerferien gewesen wären,
in denen in den USA v.a. Familien
in die Ferien fahren,
ging noch die Klimaanlage kaputt.
Jetzt hoffen sie auf viele Gäste,
trotz Nebensaison.
(Frau) Oh, wow.
Zurück auf dem Wakulla River.
Der nur 18 km lange Fluss
entspringt aus einer der
grössten Süsswasserquellen der Welt.
240 ¤ zahlen die Frauen für die Tour.
Dafür möchte Mario
ihnen auch etwas bieten.
Schau mal, die Schildkröten.
(Frau) Wow.
- Wow.
Oh, schau mal.
Aha, ja, dort ...
* Sanfte, rockige Klänge *
Es ist schön, so zu arbeiten.
Es ist auch Arbeit,
aber total anders als zuvor.
Heimweh?
Das habe ich manchmal schon auch.
Ich bin eine Person, die
wahnsinnig gern in die Berge geht.
Das ist für mich
momentan fast das Härteste.
Die Berge sind hier
halt schon nicht gerade um die Ecke.
Wow!
Seekühe und Schildkröten
anstatt Steinböcke und Murmeltiere:
das neue Leben der Tscharners.
(Mario)
* Verträumte Musik *
Und dann entdeckt Mario
auch noch den ersehnten Alligator.
(Frau)
Wasser ist auch in Island Thema.
Seit sechs Wochen hat es
im Osten der Insel kaum geregnet.
Die Trockenheit könnte zum Problem
für die Wasserversorgung
der Tiny-Häuser werden.
Steff kontrolliert den Wasserstand
der neu gebauten Quellfassung.
Der Wasserstand
wäre etwa 10-15 cm höher.
In letzter Zeit
war es halt extrem trocken.
Noch ist der Tank
mit 8'000 l gut gefüllt.
Aber schon morgen werden
die ersten Gäste Wasser verbrauchen.
In etwa einer Woche wird es
langsam knapp mit dem Wasser,
das zurzeit reinfliesst.
Die Schneeschmelze
ist bereits vorbei
und es kommt
kein Wasser mehr von oben.
Regen würde uns helfen,
aber jetzt warten wir mal ab.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Mit der der Erschliessung der Quelle
haben die Schweizer
eine weitere Hürde beim Bau
der drei Tiny-Häuser gemeistert.
Voilà.
Melde dich,
wenn du frisches Wasser brauchst.
Runter, runter.
Ja, dort.
Es ist auf der Innenseite.
Auf der Innenseite?
- Ja.- Oh, nein.
Dort sind noch drei Fliegen,
aber die lassen wir.
Ist es okay?
- Ja, ja.
Nach Monaten der Plackerei
sind Isabelle und Steff
auf der Zielgeraden.
Wollen wir sie hier draussen
oder drinnen aufhängen?
Hier fällt sie etwas mehr auf.
Draussen übersieht man sie.
Die Hausordnung darf nicht fehlen.
Wo ist der Hammer?
Oh, Mann, ich renne 100-mal
hin und her. Ich dreh durch.
* Schräge Töne *
Ach, herrje.
Fertig lustig.
* Isabelle lacht. *
Ich renne nicht mehr zurück.
Die Pfahlbauer
haben es auch so gemacht.
Gib mir mal den Bilderrahmen.
* Beide lachen. *
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Okay?
- Nein.
Hier.
- Jetzt. Okay.
Super.
- Gehen wir?- Mhm.
Wie findest du das?
- Gut.
Endlich ist alles fertig.
Fast alles.
- Oh!
(Englisch)
Eine schöne Schweinerei.
Zurück an den Anfang, was?
Mittwochs ist das Brisas del Mar
geschlossen.
Dann haben alle frei: die Mitarbeiter
und auch Gabor und Otmar.
Endlich haben die beiden Auswanderer
Zeit zum Entspannen.
Sie wohnen jetzt
im Zentrum von Cala Rajada.
Nur 3 Min. zu Fuss vom Meer entfernt.
Hier ist es viel besser,
viel heller ...
... viel farbiger ...
... und ein bisschen moderner.
Mehrmals schon sind sie
mit Hund Ronaldo umgezogen.
Hier wollen sie jetzt
erst mal bleiben.
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Wenig.
Man ist mit dem Restaurantbetrieb
beschäftigt, funktioniert einfach
und arbeitet so schnell wie möglich.
Wenn man nach Hause kommt, kann man
nicht sofort schlafen gehen.
Man ist innerlich noch nervös
bzw. mit dem Restaurant beschäftigt.
Ich nicht. Ich war einfach müde.
Wenn man sehr müde ist,
kann man nicht sofort einschlafen.
Die Tage im Restaurant sind lang.
Und während der Saison
gibt es kaum Freizeit.
Tut das gut?
- Mhm.
Seit ihrer Auswanderung
verbringen die beiden
viel mehr Zeit miteinander als zuvor.
Es ist manchmal anstrengend,
wenn man den ganzen Tag
und abends zusammen ist.
Irgendwann willst du etwas Ruhe vor
mir und ich sehr gern Ruhe vor dir.
Sehr gern.
- Ja.
Sogar sehr gern.
Wir hatten geplant, dass er
zwischendurch Zimmerstunde hat,
aber bis jetzt geht das gar nicht,
weil wir zu wenig Personal haben
und das Restaurant sehr gut läuft.
Es geht jetzt halt nicht.
Ich weiss nicht, ob die Gastronomie
wirklich Gabors Zukunft ist.
Ich verstehe schon,
dass man arbeiten muss,
aber wenn man
ganz früh morgens beginnt
und erst um 1 Uhr
wieder nach Hause kommt,
tut man eigentlich
nichts anderes mehr als zu schlafen.
* Chillige Musik *
Trotz gelegentlicher
Meinungsverschiedenheiten:
Die beiden bereuen es nicht,
den Schritt in ein neues Leben
gewagt zu haben.
Das ist lecker mit Snickers.
Sonne und Meer - das haben sie
sich erträumt und gefunden.
Auch wenn die Zeit zum Geniessen
noch zu kurz kommt.
Für mich
war es ein Sprung ins kalte Wasser,
aber ich habe sehr viel gelernt
und möchte noch besser werden.
Ich wünsche uns einfach Glück.
Wir haben viel erlebt
und wissen nun, wie es funktioniert.
In Bezug auf die Organisation
wird es sicher ruhiger werden.
Aber ich hoffe natürlich,
dass weiterhin viele Gäste kommen.
Wir sind einfach ein crazy Paar.
- Tom und Jerry.
Ja.
* Entspannte Musik *
Gib mir noch etwas davon.
Das ist lecker.
Das andere schmeckte mir nicht. Mmh!
Ihre Auswanderung
war kein Sonntagsspaziergang.
Doch sie haben nie aufgegeben.
In Florida
gibt es einen Grund zu feiern.
Ein Jahr schon lebt Familie Tscharner
im Sunshine State.
Das wäre was für dich, nicht wahr?
Mario und Melanie haben ihre neuen
Freunde zum Grillfest eingeladen.
Achtung, Mädels, geht ihr zur Seite?
Es ist heiss.- Hunger.
Ja, ich weiss, dass du Hunger hast.
Muss ich nichts tun?
- Nein.- Nur hier festhalten?
Oh!
Familie Tscharner hat den Neustart
in der Fremde gewagt - und gewonnen.
Geschäftlich Erfolg zu haben
war ehrlich gesagt fast einfacher,
als wir erwartet hatten.
(Mario)
No jumping, baby.
Rund 30 Gäste
wollen mit den Tscharners
auf ihre Auswanderung anstossen.
(Mann) Hey, little one.
Hello.
- Hello.
Auch Winky ist da, die einstige
Besitzerin des Wohnhauses.
Für Melanie ist sie wie eine Mutter,
denn Melanies Eltern
leben schon viele Jahre nicht mehr.
* Winky lacht. *
Das sind die Momente,
die es schön machen, hier zu sein.
Sie haben es uns
wirklich leicht gemacht.
* Sanfte Countryrock-Klänge *
(Mario)
Cool.
Schneller als erwartet
konnte Familie Tscharner Fuss fassen.
(Mario)
Leckst du mich auch ab?
- Geh schwimmen, geh.
Ein Haus mit Pool,
ein grosser Freundeskreis
und das eigene Business:
Die Tscharners haben sich
ihren amerikanischen Traum erfüllt.
Die Tage allerdings sind voll.
Wir brauchen die ganze Zeit Action.
Es muss wirklich etwas los sein.
Wir sagen nicht:
"In zwei Jahren machen wir das."
Das taten wir noch nie.
Ich glaube, es ist auch
dem Tod meiner Eltern geschuldet,
dass wir nie
etwas vor uns herschieben.
Wenn wir etwas tun wollen,
tun wir es -
und zwar jetzt
und nicht in ferner Zukunft.
Dadurch entstehen jedoch viele
ziemlich stressige Situationen.
Am Anfang ist natürlich alles super,
aber nun müssen wir versuchen,
die Mietunterkünfte zu optimieren,
damit das Ganze ...
... nicht extrem viel Zeit und Geld
frisst.
Wir müssen es
wirtschaftlich betreiben können.
Unser Traum ist,
dass wir hierbleiben dürfen,
dass wir unser Geschäft ausbauen
und all unsere Ideen, von
denen wir Tausende im Kopf haben,
verwirklichen können.
# Everything that I have
is just what I've got on.
# I ain't got a dime
but what I've got is mine.
# And the Lord knows I'm free.
# Amarillo by mornin',
# Amarillo's where I'll be.
Alright.
* Applaus *
Die Natur in Island hat sich für
einmal besonders schön herausgeputzt.
Tiny-Haus Nummer 1 ist fertig.
Northurljós - Nordlicht -
haben Isabelle und Steff es getauft.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Mit der Ankunft der ersten Gäste
kommt ihr anspruchsvolles Bauprojekt
zum Abschluss.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Alles begann mit einer Pauschalreise,
auf der sie ihre Faszination
für Island entdeckten.
Frisch vermählt sind Isabelle und
Steff vor etwas mehr als einem Jahr
mit einem Anhänger voller
Zügelkartons in Hergiswil gestartet.
* Isabelle seufzt zufrieden. *
Es ist wie in der Schweiz,
wenn man ins Schwimmbad geht.- Mhm.
Mit Fleiss,
handwerklichem Geschick und Ausdauer
haben sie
ihr gemeinsames Projekt verwirklicht.
Die Häuser stehen,
sie werden von Gästen bewohnt,
die Gäste sind glücklich
und wir leben noch und
haben keine Schäden davongetragen.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Etwas mehr Freizeit wäre
manchmal natürlich schön gewesen.
Es war nicht die Idee,
nach Island auszuwandern,
um dann nur noch zu arbeiten.
Aber wenn man
etwas Neues aufbauen will,
muss man sich
in den ersten zwei, drei Jahren
einfach reinknien und Gas geben.
Von Anfang an das Leben
zu geniessen, funktioniert nicht.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich das allein gemacht hätte.
Ich bin sehr dankbar dafür,
dass wir beide dasselbe wollten
und unseren gemeinsamen Traum
realisiert haben.
Ich fragte dich mal,
ob du zurück in die Schweiz willst,
wenn das Ganze in die Hose geht,
und du sagtest: "Nein."
Wir fühlen uns hier extrem wohl,
haben bereits Wurzeln geschlagen
und besitzen ein gutes Fleckchen
Erde, das uns viel Energie gibt.
Egal, was kommt -
ich glaube, ich will hierbleiben.
Bereut haben wir bisher gar nichts
und zurück wollen wir auch nicht.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Uns gefällt es hier.
- Mhm.
Komm.
- Hopp, hopp.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Schau's dir an.
* Pfiff *
Theo!
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
* Pfiff *
Theo!